I only eat non flavored lube I refused
see this as a joke it's not funny oh
wait you really do eat it whiskey dick
experience isn't a good thing I think
they're trying to take it back like it's
our thing now smells like whiskey smells
like I failed my Lissa whiskey yeah it
actually does taste like whiskey though
I'm surprised you know it's kind of good
and something you'd give a cat that has
a fungal infection I wouldn't do this I
would do this after that's really in the
mood
more than this whiskey dick not too bad
yeah in this form obviously red velvet
cake hey this is the nicest bottle I'm
seeing reow sorry carry on it even looks
like a hand soap or like an elixir this
I'm not getting a good vibe on the smell
yeah it almost smells like a perm
doesn't it's not like red velvet at all
I get a little hint
it smells like clown Europe clown girls
like clown urine how do you know what
clown urine smells like what
oh wait what the it also has a very
sharp like don't eat this yeah feeling
about it cake looks good cake looks
great and the bottle is great tagline
great taste
we got some bacon Lube they make
everything with bacon bacon doesn't make
me think of sex it makes me think of
like church oh god I need that to wash
it down
there's no bacon flavor to that at all
no the one thing to ruin bacon for that
I'll get rid of it
squirting come with natural flavors what
if this is just bottled come do it wind
without looking yeah yeah I'm totally
down oh that doesn't taste like just
taste like cough syrup it doesn't taste
anything like [ __ ] or something you
should discuss why would anyone want
that as someone who started this not
using Lube I don't think that this
tastes s is relieved convinced me I
don't know if I need it to be flavored
when it comes to lube and sexual stuff
you do you
you
[Music]